welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jeremy seakings a visiting professor
at Yale in the ethics politics and
economics department and the
International Affairs Council professor
Seekings is based at the University of
Cape Town in South Africa where he has a
joint appointment as professor of
political studies and sociology
professor seakings leads a variety of
research projects encompass atay tyvek
walla tative research these include
studies of adolescents race and class
violence aids and poverty social policy
and politics most of his research
concerned South Africa but he also
conducts research in Brazil and the
Caribbean and other parts of Africa
today we'll talk with Professor seakings
about his recent article titled
deserving individuals and groups the
post-apartheid states justification of
the shape of South Africa system of
social assistance welcome professor
seakings thank you very much as a
pleasure tell us about the premise of
your paper well this paper is a paper
looking at the South African welfare
system and South African welfare system
is quite distinctive in in many ways
which I think makes it interesting to a
variety of audiences welfare systems
around the world typically involve some
combination of water cooler social
insurance programs and social assistance
programs social insurance programs such
as Social Security in the US our
contributory program is where people
come eligible for benefits old-age
pensions or whatever on the basis of the
contributions they're making when
they're working so those are programs
that are primarily designed and intended
to provide for some financial support
for working people when they're unable
to work the other kind of program is
social assistance program and social
assistance programs what Americans call
welfare our programs which are
non-contributory generally and that they
are gent often means tested whereby
support is given to particular
categories of people on the basis
they are considered deserving so that
the poor in America get farragut
financial systems for for for medical
expenses that was the AFDC program and
for for single mothers and in many parts
of the world there was our old age
pensions for the to the elderly which
are not linked to their contribution
record but are there non-contributory
right if you like south africa's very
unusual because of africa has a very
undeveloped contributory system but a
very extensive non-contributory system
so has very limited social insurance but
very extensive social assistance this is
a very unusual combination around the
world and it has all sorts of
consequences now the one important
consequence is that with social
assistance programs is that who gets
them reflects very much who is
considered deserving by political elites
or by society as a whole depending on
the history but who who is considered
deserving what kinds of poor people are
considered deserving in South Africa
there's been a big debate about this
recently because poverty is very
extensive and many poor people are not
in those categories of the deserving
poor who have been recognized as
deserving in the design of this welfare
system the social assistance system so
in my in this particular paper of mine I
was looking at the way in which certain
group support South Africans are
identified as deserving and get covered
by the social assistance system but
other group support South Africans don't
and i was looking at why the state or
how i should say the state justifies
this inclusion and exclusion of
different kinds of poor people saying
some people are poor and other people or
not okay so give us an overview of the
social assistance system in South Africa
today so the South African social
assistance system really identifies
three groups of people as really
deserving and these are the groups of
people that would you'd expect to be
considered as deserving in in many parts
of the world and so
South Africa is not unique in in
recognizing these groups are distinctive
it's it's it's unique in the global
south in the extent to which it has has
included these groups in its welfare
system so the first is the elderly so
South Africa has a very generous system
by global standards of old-age pensions
and my papers focused on one aspect of
this that old age pensions are given to
people to women from the age of 60 and
men from the age of 65 these are
non-contributory their means-tested and
that means that when you apply you have
to show that you don't have extensive
other sources of income or great wealth
in practice ninety percent of the
elderly get the pension so that means
test is really just a way of not giving
it to retired University Professors for
example so almost everybody gets the
pension but there is a means test but if
you satisfy the means test then you this
is a pension she has a right from 60 or
65 if your women or men that's the first
part of that welfare that's a social
assistance system so the elderly they're
considered deserving the second group
we're consider deserving are are the
disabled who are unable to work but
because they are because they disabled
or chronically sick and in South Africa
this is actually become quite a
political or social hot potato because
large numbers of people have become sick
because they are sick with with stages 3
or 4 of AIDS and and so a lot of the
disability is AIDS related so there's
the second big category of people in
South Africa who are considered
deserving are the disabled in the sick
and the third category of children and
in many countries around the world there
is some recognition that that children
should NASA science ability to make sure
that children don't grow up in poverty
or at least not an extreme poverty and
in South Africa there is a system of
child or to call child support grants
and these are grants which are given to
the parents or the guardians of of
children where the where the families
are very poor and the idea is that this
will give that
family the sufficient minimum that at
least the child will not go to school
hungry and will not go to school without
any shoes and we'll have a better
opportunity in life than if there's no
support so those three groups elderly
disabled and children are identified as
deserving poor now there's a lot of poor
people who don't fit into those
categories of course South Africa is
very high unemployment and and I'm
problems of landlessness so people don't
have access to wages or earnings they
don't have access to subsistence
agricultural production it's a lot of
people who are very poor as some of
those people of course live with the
elderly they live with a grandmother or
they've got children or they live with
someone who's disabled so indirectly
they might benefit from the welfare
system although they're not considered
deserving as individuals but then
there's plenty of of poor families who
have no children of an eligible age for
the child support grants which used to
be at the age of 14 who aren't living
with the elderly or aren't disabled they
just don't have work and they don't have
land and those those people are
overlooked by the welfare system they're
not considered deserving in terms of the
design of the welfare system and so
there's some debate about should the
welfare system include some or all of
them now my paper focused on on one
particular group of of people who are
excluded which was men between the ages
of 60 and 65 so women get the old-age
pension from the age of 60 but men only
got that old age pension from the age of
65 this gender discrimination and and
this was justified by the the South
African government on a number of
grounds the first being that women are
genuinely disadvantaged and the second
that women are more benevolent and how
they use their their pensions and if you
give them money to a grandmother they're
more likely to to look of to share it
with other needy members their family
even if you give it to an elderly man so
there is two arguments which the state
used to justify why the screaming
ating in favor women and against men in
this age group 60 to 65 and I use this
as a as a case study to interrogate the
way in which to state to us constructing
its categories of who is deserving how
it how what kinds of evidence had used
to support that that argument and what
were the empirical and conceptual
normative flaws in its argument okay and
is there a difference between apartheid
and post apartheid in terms of what the
state is providing well this is this is
curious because when you tell people
that South Africa has this very
distinctive welfare system which maybe
give an example how distinctive it is so
so I Africa spends about three and a
half percent of its gdp on these social
assistance programs now we don't know
any other case in the global South which
spends more than one and a half or two
percent of GDP so so Africa is spending
more than double even places like Brazil
which has now got quite big programs are
Mauritius and other cases which are
recognized as as as unusual so it's a in
global terms it's a very distinctive
welfare system and most most people when
we talk about this most people say well
this is clearly because of
democratization and we know that from in
all sorts of fields that democratization
matters democracy matters and all sorts
of pro for reforms are more likely to
happen in a democratic than a
non-democratic environment but accuracy
in South Africa these reforms did not
follow the transition to democracy in
1994 in fact they long preceded it that
became more generous in terms of the
benefits after 1994 and they became more
extensive in the number of beneficiaries
has grown but that the core elements of
the welfare system actually go all the
way back to that to the 1920s to the
1940s in fact before even apartheid so
these are very very well established
elements of the welfare system some of
my other work I've looked at the history
of these programs and they were
typically introduced to benefit white
and woman in South car called colored
people in the relatively privileged
groups and they were quite explicitly
intended as a vehicle for discrimination
they were intended to raise the living
standards a poor white and kind of
people above the living standards or
better off African people so this was
very much part of the ideology of white
supremacy and a part 8 they governments
at the time drew on that the British
model which had our age pensions and
other forms of support for the poor but
I only applied them to the privileged
members of the privileged citizens of of
of South Africa at a time but in the
1940s they as many of these programs
were d racialized in the extent to the
extent that they were partially extended
African people and that that was a
particular moment early in the second
world war in 1940s when it happened and
that really that the system which was
put in place then survived all the way
through became much more generous in a
major part a period and and is the basis
really of this now very unusual welfare
system so it is a it's a very
long-standing system right which has its
origins in a you know in a particular
moment in time but where the outcome
today it was very different to what the
founders actually intended 80 years ago
what drew you to look at this why is
this important to study well I I look to
this book for took for two reasons the
first is that I've done a lot of work on
that comparative study of welfare
systems in the global south and maybe
say a bit more about that in a moment
but the other reason is that I was asked
to to to look at the particular question
of of why men in the 60 to 65 year old
category were excluded from the welfare
system because a group of men aged 60 to
65 brought a court case against its
African government saying that there
exclusion or to put it another way the
discrimination against men because women
of that age got the pension and the main
didn't this discrimination this
exclusion was not constitutional in
terms of the Bill of Rights which is
part of safran Constitution and it was
this constitutional court challenge
which forced the government to to
articulate much more in much more detail
than it usually would what how how
justified who was considered deserving
and who was not considered deserving but
a very strange thing was that the
government got into a big argument as to
why women were deserving not men and it
could have just said well we inherited
this near part 8 state right which would
have would have would have been an
answer but they actually got into a
justification saying that women would
disadvantage relative to men and the
lawyers for the men in the case asked
could I comment on this case and so I
was an expert witness in this
constitutional court case and and I was
able to show that that most men who
satisfied the means test were in fact
highly disadvantaged because if they'd
been advantaged in their lives if they'd
been people who had had regular
employment they would have had savings
they were had all sorts of other sources
of income which would meant that they
would be lifted above the minimum income
4444 the old-age pension so I was able
to show the what was happening was that
really disadvantaged men were being
excluded from the welfare system these
were men who probably had dropped out of
school at the age of 12 or 14 they had
spent part of that a large part of their
working lives in deep underground gold
mines they had got they'd probably got
you know the health is probably impaired
they probably had spent you know 15 20
years unemployed they had no other
source of income they had no skills
other than deep level mining and there
was no demand for those skills from from
60 year old men these men who were in
many ways really very disadvantaged and
I was able to show that that that it was
these kinds of people who being excluded
by the government's definition north
deserving poor and and as a consequence
of this court case the government in
fact reform the system and now they
would reduce the age of eligibility for
men from 65 to 60 so that men and women
are eligible the old-age pension from
the age of 60 subject to satisfying a
means test so so it has has real
practical consequence yeah now that
there are no there are millions Africa
who get the pension and are not poor not
living in poverty who without this
reform would not have been would not
have had this this source of income we
had to wait another five years yeah
that's wonderful so let's talk about how
you became to be an expert with witness
and how you gathered the data you know
that you brought so so the government's
case was based very much around around
using empirical data to show that men
and women were differentially advantage
and disadvantage the women enjoyed more
disadvantages of men and they were able
to do that fairly easily using survey
data which showed that on average women
get slightly less education and men that
they have lessened have fewer employment
opportunities and so on now I was able
to use very much the same kind of data
data from household surveys from labor
for surveys and now there's very good
survey data of this sort and so I forgot
as in many places to show that sure that
there are some men who have have really
have obvious advantages but those are
typically the men who are still working
in the early 60s and wouldn't be
claiming the pension anyway but that
there's plenty of men who actually are
you know have share many most of the
disadvantages experienced by women in
economic terms and I was able to show
that these were the people who are
really being excluded by this by this
construction of the deserving [ __ ] so i
was using survey data to link it to kind
of this very practical policy questions
right okay what did you identify as the
weaknesses in the state's framework for
their argument well the state the state
says that the state argued that
it was justified to exclude men of a
certain age but to include women on the
basis of of the of a comparison of the
the mean education the mean employment
record the mean of a number of economic
characteristics for Maine compared to
women and I was able to show that in
fact just looking at the means looking
at the average for men average for women
isn't very useful when you have
considerable diversity considerable
variation and in fact what you really
want to look at is what are the
advantages and disadvantages or
different men and different women and I
was able to show that the state had had
really had overlooked the disadvantages
experienced by large numbers of men not
all men but large numbers of men in a
way that they had constructed their
empirical their empirical arguments so
it's also an example of really that how
one should go about using survey data
for example for for scholarly purposes
and this is policy oriented scholarly
work but it's clearly very important to
look at the distribution of advantage
and disadvantage and not simply just
look at you know average or mean value
ok why is this of intellectual interest
in the comparative study of social
policy across the world do you think
well most most of my work on welfare is
is comparative looking at the global
south and south africa i think has has
two important lessons for the global
study of or social welfare and these are
really both linked to its
distinctiveness that as i said the the
most welfare systems evolved some
combination of contributory systems and
non-contributory systems social
insurance on the one hand and social
assistance on the other in the global
south most countries through the second
half of the 20th century developed
welfare systems which focused almost
entirely on the contributory side these
are systems involve pensions or health
insurance
very occasionally unemployment insurance
certainly pensions and health insurance
for workers who informal employment such
that when they were tired or if they
were sick they would be covered so most
countries in the South developed
contrary to systems which were were
coerced since they were oriented towards
workers in a formal sector so that goes
very different in South Africa had its
underdeveloped insurance system but I
have a highly developed assistance
system which wasn't aimed at workers
primarily but was aimed at non-workers
the elderly the poor elderly children
the disabled and so on so it was a very
different model to the general model in
in the global south now this is
important for two reasons and the first
is that the fact that we have cases like
South Africa reminds us that there were
are there were throughout the 20th
century choices that governments made
colonial governments post colonial
governments made about the design of
their welfare system it wasn't as if
that the standard what I call worker
with choice in other words a welfare
system focused on really urban
industrial workers like that was not the
only option there were other options in
the South Africa in fact gone down a
different route and my other research
I've looked at other examples of
countries or cases which went down a
similar route some countries in the
Caribbean mauritius for example an
Mauritius Mauritius is not in the
Caribbean but as a number of other
British colonies mostly british colonies
which went down the south african roots
of this focus on non-contributory
welfare programs now the if we look at
if we look at some Africa and these
other cases in a global context we have
to ask well why why why did they happen
and why were that why didn't they why
were there not more cases of this sort
and a lot of my comparative work is
focused on trying to understand both why
why why we have these exceptions and why
they were unusual so I've looked at a
lot of work looking at the diff
diffusion of ideas around well
fair in the only in the mid 20th century
the particular combinations of
conditions which which result in in
worker 'used or more social assistance
type programs being implemented in
different systems so that's the one
reason there's been a historical reason
to explain why do different countries go
down different paths in terms of the
design of welfare policy or or an end it
should be to other areas of public
policy as well the second reason why
it's important is it in the last 20
years there's been a huge upsurge of
interest in the kinds of programs that
South Africa has had on the books for
for a long time so much of the
enthusiasm around social policy will
form in the global South is around
programs such as the bolsa família which
is a cash transfer system it's a
non-contributory system to families with
children in Brazil and there are many
cases of over the world bank cause
conditional cash transfers of this sort
where the Brazilian case is replicated
there's also growing numbers of cases of
where countries implement
non-contributory pensions for the
elderly it'll on the South African lions
so that there is this great upsurge of
interest in this model which wasn't very
common for most of the second half of
20th century but the in the 1990s and
early two thousands has become much more
common so looking at at African case can
give us a lot more understanding of what
kinds of conditions this reduces poverty
or has particular consequences of
particular groups of people so in very
practical terms we can learn quite a lot
from studying now the South African case
precisely because it's now become a bit
of a an unexpected role model it costs
many other particle and why has it
become such a role model why the
transition well it hasn't become a role
model because people study South Africa
curiously I mean it's it's it's an
accidental role model okay it wasn't the
case that as people policymakers
scholars and other parts of the world
looked at South Africa and said wow now
here's an exciting program why don't we
copy it in fact it developments in
Brazil and Mexico other places I wish of
which have been the recent pioneers in
this kind of welfare reform it have
generally had their own particular
internal internal reasons as to why they
why they went this route often without
much knowledge of the South African case
one reason why this African case is not
well known is that the major vehicle for
knowledge about welfare systems around
the world for the last 50 years have
been International Labor Organization in
Geneva the ILO ayano connects and
disseminates much of the information
policy makers use for four we know
rethinking their their social policies
and the World Bank does the same thing
increasingly as well now the ILO
expelled South Africa in the 1960s
because of apartheid that constant
Africa had the apartheid system
discriminated against black workers the
ILO said now there is no place in il 0
for 4 partakes of Africa so it was
thrown out of the ILO and the ILO
stopped including data on South Africa
in all of its in all of its data later
sets and reports so right up until the
mid-1990s when apartheid ended so that
occur was right outside the the normal
the right outside that the world which
policy makers were drawing on when they
were designing experiments is only at
the very end of the 1990s really in the
last 10 years that people are going to
say wow if we want to know what happens
if you give the elderly old-age pensions
we can learn from the South African case
because they've been doing this for a
long time right but that Brazilians
Mexicans many other places introduced
they introduced two forms before people
had realize that there was in fact this
role model to learn from hmm interesting
well thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work well thank you very much is neither
pleasure for more information about
professor seakings and his work please
visit our website at ya
that edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you